My name's Caitlin Brodnick and I'm here
and healthy which is
like a really big deal.
I tested positive for the
BRCA1 genetic mutation
which means that I have a very high risk
of developing breast
cancer in my lifetime.
I got tested at 25 because he's the
only surviving person in his family.
They've all died of cancers,
both parents and both sisters.
I was about to lose my
insurance so I was like,
okay fine I'll go get
tested and I went in to see
if I had a gluten allergy
and they were like no.
You should really get
tested to see if you have
like this breast cancer
gene as they call it
and so I was, I tested positive for BRCA1.
When you are high risk, when you're BRCA,
your medical folder gets red tagged
and you kind of go to
the head of the class.
So that meant that not
only did I have a mammogram
when I was younger than the average woman,
but I had this MRI where
they put a contrast dye
in you and then once
the dye's in your body
you do an MRI and then they can check
and see if anything's off.
Then you have to wait for
like other information
and that whole process of like sitting
in a hospital, waiting for an MRI,
having all of it just
really freaked me out
and I just didn't want
to be in that center.
I didn't want to be
next to cancer patients
cause I felt horrible.
I felt guilty that I was
taking time away from them.
So I just ran away from it completely.
The whole thing I was like, okay
I'm not getting surveillance,
I hate my breasts
and they're really affecting my body and
my self esteem and I'm pretty miserable
and at the time doctors
were just suggesting
that women if they choose to have
a mastectomy preventatively, it's after
they're finished breast feeding,
once they're into menopause.
So I told my family and
they were all really shocked
but as I explained it and explained
how I didn't feel authentic in my body,
I felt like I was hiding, I
was not going to the doctor,
it made a lot more sense to everyone.
To have the surgery,
basically what they do
is they remove all of the breast tissue
because all of those
cells have a high risk
of becoming cancerous
and for that they remove
all of the breast tissue but
they don't go into the chest wall.
Your pec muscle stays intact.
You can choose to
rebuild or not to rebuild
and I did not know what
to choose so for me
I wanted to go really gradually because
I could not choose, like I had no concept.
I know I wanted small
breasts, smaller breasts
but like I was sick of looking
like a Russian nesting doll.
I wanted to look like a Russian ballerina.
Like I just wanted to
feel light and easy and
fun but I also had no
idea what I was doing
and I actually had to
convince a couple doctors
that this was the right decision for me,
that it was giving me a lot of
anxiety with my now husband.
Doctors told me that I
had a less than 1% chance
after I had my surgery
and I think it can change
based on women keep their nipples or
not keep their nipples, but they told me
less than 1% which is great but I still
have a risk of ovarian cancer and
with this mutation I have an elevated risk
of pancreatic cancer and melanoma.
That was something that
was a little difficult
to handle in the beginning because
when you think of having a preventative
double mastectomy you hear that and
it feels like it's a one time deal.
Just like you'd have knee surgery or
you'd have a replacement, the thing with
this type of surgery is because they are
removing body parts
and adding new implants
and your body's changing, it takes
a lot longer than you'd realize.
So going through the second surgery was
really confusing to me in a way because
I had no idea what it would be like
but I still had this really recent memory
of how it felt right as soon as I woke up
from surgery or how it hurt
to move my arm at first
and so my doctor said it was really common
that you would have these
fears that were sort of
these fresh feeling fears
but at the same time
you don't actually know how you'll feel.
So it's this like bizarre,
premature nervousness
and so that surgery happened and it was
a lot easier than my first surgery because
in the mastectomy surgery,
when they remove everything,
your full chest just feels like it's been
ripped apart but just like
it sounds disgusting, but you're fine.
It's bandaged, you're on meds, it's okay.
But your chest, your body really
feels like it was assaulted.
Like it really has to heal and in
the second surgery its a little less so.
You know, there's less
movement of the muscles.
There's less things that have to rebuild,
also when you have surgery like this when
they remove the tissue they also severe
a bunch of nerves so you really don't
have any feeling in your breasts.
So that was kind of a
crazy thing to no longer
have any feeling and
doctors told me that like
I couldn't wear, put like a hot compress
for too long or they
said you can't cook over
an open flame because
you might not feel it.
Also you can't wear underwire bras because
the bra might poke you
and you might not feel it.
Now years later I can feel pretty well
and my nerves have grown back but
in the beginning they
were very, very cautious.
If a friend asks me, should I get tested?
Do I need to get tested?
I always say, you can talk to your doctor.
They'll advise you.
You know it's up to you to get tested,
but that's a lot of information and
even though you might not have cancer
that diagnosis feels, sometimes
you feel like you have cancer.
It's around the corner and
its really hard to shake that
and so once you know, I
think it's helpful to know
and you can empower yourself but also
it's good to know, like,
is this information
going to just destroy me right
now because it did for me.
It was just too much and
it's such a crazy feeling
to have the second surgery and now to
love my body more which sounds insane,
like it sounds crazy and
if somebody said that
to me I don't know if I'd believe them
and I don't know if they
were just on some pink cloud
and just decided they
were lying to themselves
but I really feel so
much better in my body
and so much calmer and I never think of
breast cancer and I'm just really happy
that my kids aren't going to have to see
their mom go through breast cancer.
(instrumental music)